so today I'm mostly going to be talking
to you about a little classifier built
to basically detect a certain type of
star that I worked on during my time as
an astronomer so just quick introduction
I'm Sandra I'm a data scientist at lists
so if you just heard eddies talk this
morning we're an online fashion platform
we aggregate millions of products from
the web and basically we have quite a
good date science team there and we do a
lot of interesting data science so come
and grab me or any anyone else from the
data science team at list if you want to
know more about our projects because I'm
not talking about it today instead I'm
actually gonna be talking to you about
astronomy and astrophysics because
that's what my background is so I spent
a lot of time playing with this
telescope back in the day when I was an
astronomer it's in La Palma
one of the Canary Islands and it's one
of the two UK own telescopes that we
have there basically what you do is you
end up applying for time on telescopes
and you get it good for you you go out
there and you observe the stars so I'm I
was mostly an observational astronomer I
did most of my research was around
observing stars and looking for a
specific type of star which I'm going to
get to now but yeah so that's that's
mostly my background that wasn't
actually a good observing run the
weather was really bad as you can see
you can't even see the skies was just
really cloudy but still doesn't doesn't
change the fact that it was always like
super magical and and amazing when you
could go out there so as I said I have a
PhD in astronomy and astrophysics that's
my background
and while I did most of my time as an
astronomer was I search for specific
types of stars that it's easy to
describe as dead stars it's basically
what our stars are going to be at the
end of their lives they're known as
white dwarfs neutron stars or
stellar-mass black holes most of the
stars in our universe are actually going
to end up as white dwarfs by most I mean
they can--it eight percent of them and
those are the ones that I actually
focused on
and the way I did it was using what we
call a large sky surveys so their
surveys of the sky using white field
cameras attached to telescopes and they
just observe big patches of the sky in
depth using different filters and just
basically try to do as much of it and
and you end up with like really big
catalogs of stars and just objects
basically in the sky and the reason why
I focus on white Roche was a because my
supervisor was obsessed with them but
also they were the most common ones so
they were the easiest ones in a way to
look for and not only did I look for
white dwarfs I actually looked for what
we called hydrogen rich white dwarfs so
the ones that had hydrogen in their
atmospheres because they were also the
most common ones and okay I did I won't
go into too much detail I looked for the
ones that were also pulsating but that's
just like a side point and I mostly used
as I said large sky surveys to do that
and I'll get to explain to that really
quickly and what the way I did it was I
used color color diagrams to select the
stars that I thought that I basically
thought were white dwarfs and then the
way you then confirmed their identities
and you know for sure that they are
white dwarfs is by using spectroscopy
so basically sky surveys are as I said
observations of big patches of the sky
using different filters and what you do
with the what you get with the filters
is basically the brightness of a star in
certain wave band ranges and what's
great about that is that you can then
determine the color of a star when
you've got there brightnesses in
different filters because just the the
difference between the brightness of a
star in different filters is what we
call a color and the color is a very
cheap and rough proxy of a star's
effective temperature so you can have a
rough idea if a star is basically bright
and blue filters so blue colors it's hot
whereas if it's bright in red then it's
quite it's cooler than a bright blue
star so you can if you know the
properties of the stars that you're
looking for then you can basically just
decide okay I know it's gonna be quite
blue because it's got is a hot star I
should look at blue filters and then and
then kind of like select my candidates
using using that so here is basically
what I used oh it's not really you can't
really see the labels on the side but
yeah this is basically what a color
color diagram looks like those are the
ones that I used to look for my white
dwarfs and you basically have a space in
the color color diagrams where you have
an idea of where they're gonna fall
basically the black greyish areas or
where it's what we call the main
sequence and it's where most of the
stars will spend most of their lives in
so that's why they're like really dense
areas and in a in a plot like that and
then white dwarfs are obviously not as
common as most stars in the universe so
then they'll sit in like slightly
outside regions and the dotted lines are
just theoretical lines but anyway I
basically had this like found this area
in color space where I could find my
white dwarfs and the reason why these
actually fall in quite a distinct region
here I've got the R minus H alpha color
there is because they're hydrogen rich
so they've got quite strong hydrogen
absorption lines in there in their
spectra and that's why they actually
stand out really well so I could like
very confidently say these are probably
why doors and now I only way to confirm
them is by using spectroscopy yeah so
these are colors so so R is basically a
filter that was it's a red filter in the
in the survey that I used I is another
filter uge as well and then there's a
chopper which is also another sort of
reddish filter and the difference in
filters is the color of a star so
those are just two different color color
diagrams basically and this is more like
a reddish one and this is remove and
this is a blue sort of color color
diagram and yeah so depending on like
the types of stars that you're looking
for you can then use the color space to
have a rough idea of like you know the
top-left corner there's were like the
really the blue hot stars live and then
the further down bottom right corner you
go the cooler they will be basically a
dot a dot here those ones yeah they're
actually all white dwarfs the circles
and the ones and then the grayscale is
like its I just bend them because there
are a lot more dots like there were
millions of stars and in that catalog so
I just basically just use a grayscale -
yeah yes yeah each one of those circles
and squares is actually one star in the
in the sky in our in our own galaxy
because that's why they looked at so
yeah and then as I said the only way to
actually confirm these stars is to look
at their spectra and a spectrum of a
star is basically its light intensity is
a function of wavelength as you can see
here so that's just the flux and then
the wavelength in angstrom this is an
optical wavelength because most of the
observations you do from the ground you
use like optical an optical range and
this is actually the spectrum of a white
dwarf and a hydrogen rich white dwarfs
the lines that you see these absorption
lines are hydrogen lines and it was
taken from a survey called the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey sdss which is a
really big survey that was designed and
done in the US by astronomers there and
basically what what happens in when when
you measure the spectrum of a star what
you see is the light that the photons
like the pass through a cooler gas so
typically the atmosphere of the star and
then a before it reaches you the
observer and that's where the absorption
is happened and that's where you can
detect what elements are in the in the
atmosphere of the star and that's how
you can know exactly what type of star
it is so this is kind of like what you
what you look for is you're looking for
a white dwarf you want it to look kind
of like this or a DA white dwarf like a
hydrogen rich white dwarf and just
quickly to explain spectroscopy what
happens is you you place like an
adjustable slit at the focal point of a
telescope and then you you get user
kilometre to get parallel rays and then
a grating a grater two different
disperse the light and then you detect
it into a detector and that's what kind
of like gives you all the different
wavelength range that you get so I spent
a lot of my time using surveys to pick
up my stars and then go and and and then
get their spectra and confirm their IDs
which was great because I only had 50
white dwarfs to go and confirm those
were the number of candidates I had not
a huge amount of white dwarfs at ado but
then I shared an office with a student
who used to sit there for hours and I'm
not exaggerating days probably
manually classifying spectra of stars
and he was also we had the same
supervisor so he was also looking for
white dwarfs and what he did was sit
there by this code that would plot the
spectrum of the star mostly from SDSS so
this survey that I just mentioned and
and he had those keys on his keyboard
that he said okay that's a white dwarf
and that's a a type sorry that's a
whatever type star that's a quasar
that's whatever and he did that for
hours and hours and days and days and I
just felt so sorry for him because it
just seemed like frustrating but he had
to do it to confirm that his method of
selecting them was correct and then when
I left astronomy and I joined list and I
discovered this whole world of data
science and machine learning and all
that I just thought to myself well
that's that's silly why did you get a
PhD student to do that why don't we just
build a model to actually classify those
stars that were after and since we've
got so much data well surely it's a
simple problem right like it's to me at
least it seemed like if you're if you're
after one type of star then you can
please build the simple simple
classifieds do that so I emailed my
supervisor and I was like can you send
me some data freeze I've got this like
although I want to build just to play
around and see what it's like so he did
he sent me about 8500 spectra of da
white dwarfs from the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey and then he also sent me about
16,000 spectra of non tea a white horse
that's all I know about them I just know
they're not white horse most of them
actually look like this and this is a
quasar which is basically a really
really bright object that's a hundred a
hundred thousand times 100 times
brighter than the then our own galaxy
it's not within our galaxy it's much
further away and and yeah so it looks
really different to a white work so this
is actually I think sdss was designed to
mostly find quasars so there were loads
but in color space if you're not using
something like the H alpha filter they
actually sit around where the white
dwarfs it as well so they they do have
very similar colors to white dwarfs and
they will contaminate your your white
dwarf candidates and and so a lot of the
times when you're actually gonna go and
get spectra of what you think are white
dwarfs using your color color diagrams
you're gonna find a lot of quasars and
vice versa so that's why I had a lot of
quasars in my data set so I'm found with
a binary classification problem
it's quite simple you've got you know
either a white dwarf or non-white dwarf
and I just thought okay that's simple
I'm got labeled data I'm just gonna read
my images process them feed them into
some classifier and then that's it my
problem is solved and so that's kind of
what I did I used to process the images
I used a brisk image descriptor and
basically a descriptor is it's a type of
function that that you apply to your
image to describe it in a way that it's
invited to changes and most we we
actually use the brisk image descriptors
that list to detect duplicates so it's
really great if you've got like two
images of products are taken from
different angles and stuff like Eddie
and Calvin at least they they used the
Bristol scripture to actually detect a
lot of them and the duplicate products
that we had and then so yeah each
descriptor depending on the one that you
use has a sampling pattern this is the
one that the brisk descriptor has and
and yeah so for the for my problem each
descriptor was actually what are feeding
as a feature of of my of my data so for
each image I had basically a descriptor
and a label I split the data into 80%
training set 20% testing I used a scaler
and for all of this and their support
vector machine to form a classifier and
then I then used just to check the
accuracy of my model I also used
cross-validation and to go even deeper
what I did was actually look for the
best parameters using grid search this
this bit took the longest it actually
ran for about ten hours which to me was
quite long but that was on my laptop I
didn't I didn't use anything fancy for
that and at the end what I got was a
model that could classify white dwarfs
with an 85% accuracy which to be honest
compared to a page D student after days
of doing this is probably not far off a
human would do like when I when I turn
around to my supervisor like my
supervisor and I told him that he was
like oh that's that's not far off for
any color probably had okay that's good
but I like I'm like we can definitely
achieve better though it's like such a
simple problem and the white dwarfs
looks so different to to the quasars
that mostly were the nandi a white dwarf
so surely we can get better than that
anyway I had a chat with Eddie atlas and
he was like oh I should definitely use
neuron that it's like you're definitely
gonna get much better than that so it's
like okay fine so that's gonna be like
the next step but yeah most of the time
it I also looked at the confusion matrix
to see like how often it misclassifies
things and then what I also did was I
should go
deeper and see when it was when stars
were well classified and not very well
classified so these were all classified
as white dwarfs the white rose they all
look like white dwarfs in some cases
they're very noisy spectra because
that's probably a really faint one and
then in other cases they're they're not
as noisy probably much brighter one and
then those were the nandi white dwarfs
that the model found which like compared
to the white dwarfs I mean come on they
are 3d really different so it's it's
good it works but then you get the ones
that were not classified very well so
that was classified as in nan da and I
was like why that is a white dwarf I
mean it does actually look like one but
in some cases actually I'm not surprised
they were misclassified so this one for
example this is a white dwarf a da white
worth but it was classified as a non TA
and compared to most white dwarfs the
absorption lines are actually not as
broad as you would expect them to be so
you know it's it's not very surprising
and then in this case like this one's
not as obvious either but there's an
extra like few absorption lines in
different bits that are not expected in
energy a white dwarf so that's why it
this shouldn't be classified as a deride
work but it actually did classify as one
so these are examples I don't know why
this one was classified as a day of
white or if I mean this one's quite
obvious but anyway I thought I'd look
into it and see why I mean see the cases
that if the cases were obvious or not
that were misclassified anyway I moved
on from the from this this approach and
I thought okay well let's go and look
into neural nets and see if we can
achieve a better accuracy using that so
I did that I I in the first case I used
open C B to do a lot of the image
processing because they they do have a
built-in risk function that you could
use but in the deep learning case I just
need to read the images and so I use
pillow and and then I process the images
to get it to be a 224 by 2 and 24 image
and because that's what most
architectures they're actually
so I cropped them and then in the case
of the deep neural net what I did was I
actually used a balanced data set so I
had 50% white dwarfs and 50% non white
dwarfs just because when I wasn't using
a balanced data set my accuracy wasn't
as good as when I just decided to use
the finite state set so um I thought
okay that's I'd stick to that that
method instead so I stuck to 8,500 J
white dwarfs and about 8590 a white
horse so I had nearly 17,000 points
they're all labeled as well and that's
sort of the architecture that I use I
used chorus for it just because that I
just found it more natural to understand
but I'm sure it would work perfectly
well with you know China or anything
else that you use it's about five layers
and and yeah and then the month the
difference here is that you've basically
all my images are black and white so
that's why it's 1 and then 2 and 24 by
2024 so yeah that's kind of like the
architecture that I use I'm gonna push
all this to github so if anybody wants
to have a look at it into more details
then you'll get sorry yeah it's crazy
so so yeah so then that's basically how
you kind of like fit the model you use I
used an SGD optimizer and then I ran it
for 10 a pox and using mini-batches a
100 and and yeah and then I basically
evaluated my model so that trained in
about 5 minutes like didn't take long at
all oh I did use our GPU though so maybe
that's why it was and and yeah and then
in this case in the using a neural net I
got a 99% accuracy which is like huge
compared to what I was getting before so
I thought and that was about 10 days ago
so I thought oh my god this is this is
great I need more data and I need more
like better label date I need to
basically know what the Nandi white
dwarfs are and tried to like approach
the problem differently because
are many classes of stars and if I can
achieve this with just like a binary
problem like surely I can I can sort of
like do the same with even like even
more complicated cases so I sent an
email to my supervisor I don't have
access to a strong like the data from
surveys anymore but he still didn't get
back to me so I couldn't actually build
like or like look into a more
complicated case but that is definitely
something I would like to play around
with at some point so if there are any
astronomers here that do have access to
data then please come and let me know
and yeah so basically as I said the next
step is to probably get more data and
see how I could cut if I could classify
more stars because right now I mostly
just looked at DIY drawers just because
that's what I worked on during my PhD
and it's great but to be fair most
astronomers aren't actually interested
in DIY drawers so it's probably gonna be
exciting for a small group but not not
everyone last time I checked the if
anyone's been like if anyone's done a
lot of like or anyone's built a
classifier for four stars the last paper
I personally saw was like from 2013 but
maybe I'm wrong maybe people are working
on them so if that's the case then I'd
be really interested to see what they
were using and they were and that at
that time they were using random forests
actually so it's different method
completely and then yeah so I'd like
more data I'd like to retrain the model
and then the reason why this is like
super interesting and actually like
really useful not just something that I
don't decide is that the next
generations of telescopes and satellites
out there are mostly going to be
spitting out data for like millions of
stars and one go and you I mean no
matter how many PhD students you have
you're not gonna be able to get them to
classify them all like let's face it you
need you you actually need to have like
some models to do it for you so so yeah
I think that's why it's like in a way
it's kind of interesting and something
that to look into and maybe something to
give back to astronomy since since I
spent so much time doing it so thank you
all
I'm not sure where my last slides gone
oh yeah okay it's it was on my screen
out there I just put the link to our
blog at list if anyone's interested in
reading what we're up to
I do actually have the data but then I
thought of using and so I thought of
using the images just because most of
the time that's what you get from like
if you're talking to different people
I've we don't all use sdss data at the
end of the day I actually all of the the
stars that I looked at were from another
telescope and but they were within the
same optical wavelength range so I just
thought like if someday someone just
sent me the image of like a spectrum in
an image format I thought that would be
like pretty easy to to feed into a model
it's actually more complicated if you've
got the raw data you could achieve
better using the first method I'm sure
but then I just I just thought of like
looking at it in a more complicated way
yes so I was just looking at Astro Phi
like a couple of days ago definitely
something I look into as well
I just I just normalized the flux that's
the only thing I did oh the the bris the
bris descriptor so I no no no the deep
yearning I just all I did for the deep
learning if it the neural net was
resized them into like 224 by 2024 for
the bris descriptor so I'm trying sorry
let me just get back to that so to be
honest I used open CV which which has
the breast descriptor calculator
built-in and I I wish I could actually
tell you a lot about it but I I read a
blog posts about descriptors and to kind
of have an idea of what they roughly do
they have a sampling pattern and in this
case it was just the one that I was told
works best in terms of like rotation and
and elimination of like of images and
stuff not that I have that problem in my
case but I was just told that it's it's
probably one of the better descriptors
to use and I just so for each image I
just calculated this descriptor and then
fed that into thee know yeah exactly so
the way but to get the spectrum of a
star is actually quite expensive in
terms of time on a telescope and and and
time on periscope is super expensive I
mean like you're thousands of
astronomers applying for for time on a
telescope that you know like we've got
access to two telescopes from the UK in
the northern hemisphere technically so
it's it's not it's not that easy so what
you do is you kind of like use the color
color diagrams to get a smaller sample
of candidates that you're kind of like
quite confident they're gonna be the
star that you the type of star that
you're looking for and then you go get
the spectra of these starts to identify
them like to be sure about them yeah
exactly the
yeah sure then
I mean I think they're very obviously
different most like as in in both cases
the day white horse with versus the non
da white horse and I think in that case
like they deal with images much better
like the deep nets so that's my guess of
why it was so much better
no I think is because in the case of the
deep net but it does it like it detects
like obvious points and in the in the
images so like in the case of the
quasars you've got like really obvious
emission lines that you don't have in
Jay white or example that also lie in
different parts of the of the image in a
way in like the emission line is it's
quite in the blue end so like the
smaller wavelengths and I think that
using using the deep no and I was using
a convolutional neural net so you've got
like it does pick out like distinct
features in the image in a way and I
think it will it will probably pick out
the emission line versus the absorption
lines that's that's what I'm guessing
compared to the compared to the year in
almost SVM that I was using okay sorry
yeah mr. Specter and the wise survey I
think it's mostly photometry yeah no I
most agree I'm after spectra in this
case sorry yeah you've been waiting
I guess you can
I'm I think in my case is probably like
I actually want to classify stars so
it's that's why I'm after that kind of
data I'd like to be able to have a model
that can very confidently say this is
like you know this type of service is
that and I mean there are quite a few
classes of stars so then that's that's
kind of like what ultimately I'd like to
get to
yeah I didn't actually go that far and
check how far away from the resolution I
am but you can you can still in the case
of like a day white or versus a quasar
you would still be able to see them
pretty this like easily but then in the
case of other stars I think that's when
you're gonna probably have to think
about you know like your approach to
process how you process the image before
you feed it in because an a-type star
like a star like our Sun g-type star you
basically you you will have strong
absorption lines and maybe when you
resize the image you won't see how broad
the absorption line is versus like a
white dwarf versus a normal star so then
you could actually have an issue but in
yeah in my case like it was such a
simple problem that I didn't I didn't
actually have to worry about that at all
but it's definitely something to take
into account when I had when I get more
data for sure
yeah
yeah no I didn't look at I'm literally
just using spectra yeah I did I we don't
have redshift information but that could
be an extra indication but I'm not sure
something like
sdss would would automatically give you
that information like I think you need
to actually measure like you need to get
multiple spectra measure the how your
lines move right from from one another
and then calculate the redshift I don't
know I didn't I didn't do any extra
galactic sign so yeah in this case I'm
een he actually did get proper work done
but then to you know to confirm a lot of
a lot of the theory that he was after it
was he had to eyeball a lot of spectra
yes
good question there aren't that many no
but it's true there aren't that many
postdocs available after you finish your
your degree unless I mean there are but
they're not on the UK and you have to be
really flexible to move and and all that
I personally wasn't so I guess that's
why but then I also think that you a lot
of astronomers use Python a lot which
helps when you try to switch to data
science and then yeah
just doing a lot of maths and stuff
ginger fish you probably also gets you a
job in data science so yeah surveys I
guess are considered big data
yeah but like also big catalogues have
starts so those surveys have like
millions and millions of stellar objects
in them
so just you know like you do have to
query databases and you do have to to
eventually like process a lot of data to
get to like for me to get to the 50 wide
works that I found like I had to go
through a lot it wasn't it wasn't that
simple like I at the same time released
a catalog of like 14 million stars so I
guess you're right you do deal with a
lot of big data at the same time if if
if you do play with surveys
no I do I would like to go that I would
like to look into that but I just
managed to get it to work like oh just
five layers sorry no the only thing I
did was change the data set from
non-balanced dataset to a balanced data
set that was the that's what gave me
like a huge difference in improvement
but I didn't I didn't really remove
first I thought oh let me just go all
out and try a vgg sort of model and that
was like that was taking ages and then I
just went back to like an alux neck type
but I didn't I didn't think of removing
any of the layers I could play around
and then just see how much worse or
better it goes yeah okay yeah
I could I didn't I didn't think of doing
that
in the case of the it was about 20% as
well yeah sorry yeah yeah it was about
20% I I split the dataset manually I
shuffle them and then split them into
about 20%